ونعود الى اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
والمحلل العسكري والاستراتيجيه من عمان
لواء دويري كنا نتحدث عن ان الحدث هو في
رستوف بينما يتم الان دخول مقر قوات في
سنه بطرس وكما تفسر ان المقر يقتحم بينما
يسمح
بدخول الاراضي الروسيه والسيطره على
المنشات العسكريه بما في ذلك المطار
طبيعه الهدف اختلاف طبيعه الهدف عندما
نتحدث عن مقر لا نتحدث يبدو انا هذا المقر
غير محميا وهذا المقر كان في مامن ولا
يوجد ما دلائل توحي
باقتحامه وبالتالي كاقتحام اي مبنى عادي
ليس بذلك العمل لا يحتاج الى التحذيرات
العسكريه الكبيره لكن عندما نتحدث عن
ريستوف نتحدث عن حركه 25000 يعني قبل قليل
كان هناك خبر عاجل وهذا الخبر قد يكون
اكثر اهميه مما يجري كورستوف عندما يقول
تم السيطره على كافه المنشات العسكريه في
بورنيج الجنوب موسكو نظره الى الخارطه
تقع في منتصف المسافه بين روستوف وموسكو
هل القوات قوات فاجنر استكملت المهمه
وقامت بتطويق المقرات في روستوف
تحركت باتجاه موسكو تنفيذا لتهديد بانه قد
يتحرك الى موسكو كيف وصل الى بورنك بورنيك
هي تقع في منتصف المسافه وهي مئات
الكيلومترات كيف قطعها اذا كما قلت لك في
البدايه كره الثلج تتحرك تكبر تكبر الحجم
اتجاهات الحركه غير معروفه القول الفصل
عند الرئيس بوتين ولكن السؤال هل الرئيس
بوكل بوكل الان يملك من اوراق القوه ما
يمكنه من وضع الخطوط الحمراء بطرفي الصراع
لان الجيش الروسي هو ذراع الايمن
قوات قادروف وبريجوجل الذراع الايسر
فبالتالي كلاهما يمثل اطار حركه عسكري
لتنفيذ اراده الكريم في التوجهات السياسيه
وبالتالي لا يستطيع ان يعطل كلتا اليدين
ويصيبها بالشلل عليه ان يجد موازنه
ومقاربه
قدر الامكان تفضي الى توافق ما هل هذا هل
يملك القدره
تاريخيا هو دوله الراس الواحد دوله
الخط العمودي في النظام السياسي هو يضبط
ايقاع كافه من حوله لكن يبدو انما اشارته
التقارير الغربيه منذ اكثر من سته اشهر ان
هناك خلافات داخل البيت الكرملين هناك
حديث تحت الطاوله وبالتالي هل بدا العقد
المحيط في
قتل يتداعى لا اقول يتفكك لكن تتداعى
الخطوط الربط بينهما وهذه هي البدايه ما
يجري الان بين وزاره الدفاع ورئاسه
الاركان
والمنظمه الخاصه فاجنر لكن الساعات
القادمه ستكشف الامور من بعدين ما هو موقف
الرئيس بوتين ماذا سيقول الرئيس بوتين
وماذا ما هي الخطوه اللاحقه لقوات فاجنر
بعد ان وصلت
ماذا ستعمل بعد ذلك هل تواصل الطريق الى
موسكو الحديث سيكون مختلف كليا هل تتوقف
هل تعود الى روستوف اذا الساعات القادمه
هي التي
ستحسم الامور وتجلي الضبابيه عن المشهد
لانه بالتاكيد هناك العديد من التفاصيل لم
يتم تغطيها ولم نطلع عليها يعني كيف تتوقع
اللواء
يؤثر هذا على عمليه روسيا العسكريه في
الوقت الذي تتصدى فيه للهجوم المضاد من
اوكرانيا
الان اداره العمليات هناك قياده عسكريه
مستقله وبالتالي هي تمارس مهامها انا
اتحدث عن توسيع توسيع الادوار القوات
الروسيه التي تقاتل يفترض ان هناك قائد
منطقه العمليات قاده الخلاله قاده الفرق
حتى ادنى مستوى يمارسه نعم ستلقي بظلالها
في البعد المعنوي سيحدث ارتباك ولكن عندما
نكون تكون القوه داخل معركه هي تركيزها
يكون على فوهه البندقيه اكثر من عن سماع
الاخبار القادمه من الخلف لكن بالضروره ان
تلقي بالظلال لكن ما هي التداعيات القادمه
الى اين تسير الامور هذا هو الذي
سيلقي بظلاله اذا الان بريجوجن استطاع ان
يفرض ارادته
ويجبر الرئيس بوتين او يلزمه على الاقل
بات في اجراءات بحق القيادات العسكريه
الان هل سيكون هناك انتقالا سلسا للقياده
الجديده هل سيظهر سيصنع نجم
وبالتالي ويتولى القياده وهو على علاقه
طيبه مع بريجوجن اذا ماذا سيجري في
الساعات القادمه هو الذي سيلقي بظلاله اذا
تساعدت الامور كثيرا ودخلت القوات فاجنر
باشتباكات مسلحه هذا الامر يعني استدعاء
قوات لاحتوائها واحباط محاوله الانقلاب
الان ننتقل من من تمرد الى انقلاب عند ذلك
ستبدا التاثيرات
القاسيه على القوات المقاتله وبالتالي اذا
تمكنت اوكرانيا ان تستغل هذا الظرف قد قد
تحدث تغييرات كبيره لصالحها